[Music]
as the men go you're in better shape
than most you seem to take really good
care of yourself like that yeah that's
no slam on Cheadle
but I'm just saying use it seems like
you
what do you are you working out like
crazy what kind of stuff you do you know
I do do twice a year I do a triathlon
Oh your triathlon guy well I mean it's
not like the Ironman it's like the
classic distance which is half mile swim
19 mile bike and four mile run I do this
Nautica triathlon it's great event it
benefits a children's paid pediatric
hospital cancer hospital here raised
millions of dollars and I do it twice a
year and the first time I did it was it
didn't go well right well here's what
I've always thought I've always thought
because people have said to me you know
clearly I workout as well and I have
worked out twice the point being that I
always thought when it came to something
like a triathlon that I thought okay I
could I loved a bike so I could do the
biking and I can run but the swimming is
always feels like that's the that's the
deal breaker for me yes because it's
great isn't it it's a lot of swimming
you're smarter than I they start with
the swim for a reason I thought I can
bike I can run the swim I know how to
swim I went to a pool and did it did a
few laps I'll be fine
big mistake big mistake so what was what
was wrong I think you you if you can
swim and you did some laughs wholly
unprepared I I got they are all these
triathletes and it's exciting first of
all it's it's 7:00 in the morning I
don't do anything at 7:00 in the morning
especially jump in the ocean right so
they shoot the gun off and we run down
and it's exciting and everyone's so
serious and I dive into the water and
immediately I realize my big mistake is
I've been training in the pool that's 80
degrees and what's the water it was 56
on that day oh whoa okay yes and I I
went to the water and it felt like
someone hit me with a Taser right like
all the oxygen of my body went and I
came up like not everybody came up
swimming I came up like this dog hold
and people kicking me in the face and I
was like disoriented didn't know what I
was doing and yeah there's these three
buoys I saw from the beach that you swim
out to one and then around the others
and it took me so long just to get out
to the first buoy and I was like I can't
catch my breath why did you become
Southern
can I catch my breath I don't know
something about when your oxygen lease
your pocket yeah you become southern
yeah so so what did you do I mean you
did you you just got out of it well I
finally made it to like where were you
come around the first buoy and I
realized how far the buoys were I was I
couldn't believe it I was like I'm in
big trouble so I thought I better just
put my head down and get after this even
though I'm so cold I try and object to
I'm too cold and then I just started
swimming I got about two two minutes of
freestyle when I looked up I was like
where is I've realized I'd been swimming
basically out to Hawaii really yeah so
now you're away from the buoys totally
disorientate running out of oxygen yes
yes and and and when you run or bike if
you stop you can just take a take a
breath when you swim you can't right
you'll drown right
finally I basically just doggie paddled
the entire thing right and got got in
and I remember a guy looked at me when I
was getting on the water he goes dude
you're you're gray I thought you'd be
blue if you were in that I guess there's
I think after blue is great yeah which
is yes gray is worse than blue but you
did finish that's the important thing
like to me it's all about if you're
finished then you've earned your stripes
I did but as my friend looked up our
times he pointed out that in the swim I
got beat by two minutes by teri hatcher
yeah and six minutes by Betty White
[Laughter]